hi I'm Hannah I'm the world's okay his
mom and I'm here to give you some
marginally helpful advice about stuff
you want to know oh my okay um I don't
know if you guys noticed but a little
different about me today this was a late
night decision to dye my hair pink I've
had it blue for a year I regret
everything I do not like it at all I
look like a [ __ ] Easter egg I look
like strawberry shortcake I look like a
bad wig I look like one of those
mannequins at a sex shop
so speaking of not feeling so great
about your appearance a lot of you guys
texted in asking for me to talk about
how to be more confident in high school
so let's do it
tonight's topic is how to be confident
in high school let's go
so first probably the most important
piece of advice I can give to somebody
in high school right now is to not
pretend to be something you're not
if there's something you like don't
pretend that you don't like it just to
fit in if there's something you don't
like don't pretend to be interested in
it just to fit in for example I had the
most humongo crush is that a word
no humongo crush on this boy in high
school he had like those big diamond
earrings in each earring and his
favorite band was Third Eye Blind should
have been a red flag at the time but he
was pretty cute so when I finally got a
chance to talk to him I'd already
thoroughly stalked his Facebook I knew
that he loved throw tide lines so I
brought something up about music and
he's like Lea my favorite band Third Eye
Blind and me stupidly says oh my god
they're my favorite bands too
and I had never heard one of their songs
before so this just totally snowballed
into me like binge listening to these
shitty songs all night long and posting
their lyrics as my facebook status to
just be like see a true fan I don't like
the hurt I blank like I don't like a
single one of their songs things did not
work out with this guy clearly for more
reasons than just the Third Eye Blind I
just showed me that if you go into
something from the start being honest
there would have been more chain
success in the long run had I just
stayed true to myself no offense to
Third Eye Blind fans no offense to Third
Eye Blind you work hard you worked hard
you you earned whatever six add on are
they successful I don't know or care Oh
next body issues I feel like every teen
ever has body issues at some point in
their time in high school and if you
don't [ __ ] you not fair I went through
so much huh first of all a lot of things
are happening to your body that you
can't control it's dictated by hormones
it's dictated by all sorts of other
things that have nothing to do with you
second it's temporary it's not you're
not gonna always be going through
puberty for the rest of your life this
is like a means to an end so think of it
like that
if you're feeling insecure about your
body in high school it's not always
gonna look like that take me for example
this is something that I like to keep
secret so I love you guys and that is
why I'm sharing this here's a picture of
what I looked like in high school yeah
it's not pretty I did not look that
great in high school but then I
blossomed into a butterfly
hmm next find your tribe this really
goes back to what I'd been talking about
before with like putting your true self
out there and not trying to be something
you're not
you need to find people who share the
same interest as you you need to find
your people who you can trust and feel
comfortable with being your true self it
might not be at high school because the
sample size in high school is so tiny my
graduating class was a hundred kids 40
of which were girls to find a core group
of girlfriends I had 40 people to choose
from there's no way that there's going
to be an even distribution of interests
amongst those 40 people so you might not
find a group in high school you might
find it totally in somewhere you'd never
expect like a dance company or a club
soccer team or even online because there
are so many resources online for people
who share similar interests because
let's be honest we're all weirdos we're
just all different types of weird so you
find someone who's your type of weird
you'll feel so much better
I've barely done any damage to that
bottle and finally high school is only
four years think about your entire life
and how long it's going to be compared
to the four years that you're in high
school seriously I pity that I gotta
burp so bad and it's stuck okay finally
oh okay
and I'm not discounting what you go
through in high school like those
memories are still fresh for me I know
I've been out of high school for a long
time but I remember what it's like and
those four years feel like 400 years I
feel sorry for the people who think back
on high school as the best years of
their life there's so much life to be
lived after high school you're gonna get
a job you're gonna have a career you
have the opportunity to have a family
you're gonna be able to travel there's
wine you enjoy wine when you turn 21 I
know some of you drink wine while you're
in high school and I'm not condoning
that you wait till you're 21 so don't
worry about high school being the best
years of your life be your soul on your
[ __ ] if you love it great I'm happy for
you if you don't also I'm happy for you
because you're gonna experience so much
better stuff so if you're having a tough
time in high school which I know a lot
of you are because you're reaching out
to me and watching all these videos just
know that there's a light at the end of
the tunnel I know that you're gonna be
great I hope you know that you're gonna
be great and I can't wait to see what
you become when it's time come out with
us the one with me when you're 21
let's I got four today I'm Hannah the
world okay aslam as always if there's a
topic you want me to talk about in the
future leave it in the comments or text
me I read all of them I don't
necessarily respond because I get a lot
but I love to read them and see what you
guys want me to talk about in future
episodes and if you're a teen in high
school watching this for advice turn the
phone off watch a couple more of my
episodes if you want but like turn the
phone off
go do something nice for yourself and
get some sleep for those of us who can't
please till next time there was this big
fat back in the day when I was in high
school that was white wifebeaters with
black bras underneath and we went to
cheer camp and we all packed our white
feeders with black bras and wore them
all matching the first day of cheer camp
and got food so